[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver après ce week
end particulièrement agitée pour cause
de gilet jaune et les gilet jaune on en
parlait justement ce sera le premier
sujet du jour gérald darmanin le
ministre du budget a vu la peste brune
samedi sur les champs-elysées et vous
avez vous vu la même chose on en parlera
on parlera aussi de la dernière
initiative du président de la république
qui veut créer un haut conseil pour le
climat est ce une bonne idée ou juste un
comité théodule de plus vous nous
donnerez votre point de vue par là aussi
de la france insoumise qui va pas trop
bien en ce moment à peu gêné aux
entournures par le mouvement des gilet
jaune et puis il ya eu cette élection
législative partielle c'était hier dans
l'essonne et le candidat de la france
insoumise a fait un score assez modeste
et surtout avec beaucoup d'abstention
face aux députés nouvellement élus celui
qui a été soutenue par la république en
marche
et puis nous parlerons de ce pacte de
l'onu sur les migrations qui part du
principe que l'émigration est un
phénomène inéluctable il faut mieux les
encadrer
la france va signer ce pacte beaucoup
d'autres pays et pas seulement les états
unis ne le ferons pas on vous demandera
votre point de vue sur ce sujet bonsoir
caroline valentin merci d'être là vous
êtes et céistes collaboratrice entre
autres du figaro vox d'être coauteurs
d'une france soumise est contributrice
du nouvel antisémitisme en france de
livre paru chez albin michel pour soir à
nogent premier tri ganozzi vous êtes
directeur de l' agence de la
communication que de l' agence de
communication que vous avez créé fouroux
vous avez aussi été entre autres choses
le directeur de la communication de jean
luc mélenchon pendant sa campagne
présidentielle de 2012
voilà je n'ai pas oublié alexis pas
aussi bon soir le cofondateur du média
en ligne le monde moderne point médias
vous tenez divers chronique sur
différents médias donc le média pardon
c'est pas simple deux d'entre eux
portait d'ailleurs et qui était qui
avait été créée par des proches de jean
luc mélenchon en tout cas dans une
première version et jean christophe
buisson est là aussi bonsoir directeur
adjoint du figaro magazine des veaux est
aussi le présentateur de l'émission
hebdomadaire historiquement chose chez
l'histoire est votre dernier livre écrit
avec emmanuel fc les grands vaincus de
l'histoire et ça a été publié chez
perrin en août dernier on commence donc
par un retour sur les mouvements ou plus
exactement les violences engendrées par
les gilet jaune c'était samedi dernier
sur les champs elysées gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics
il ya vu une manifestation de la peste
brune c'est ce qu'il a dit hier c'était
dans grand jury rtl le figaro lci
et ce ne sont pas des gilet jaune que
manifester c'est la peste brune qu'un
magnifique mais aussi wii vous appelez
ça comment des gens qui retirent des
pavés sur les champs-elysées qui
déballent ans sur des gendarmes sont des
policiers qui frappent des journalistes
vous appelez ça comment vous appelez ça
des gentilhommes qu'il faut respecter
non
christophe castaner quant à lui pour
qualifier ces débordements a expliqué
que c'étaient des séditieux qui
voulaient s'en prendre aux institutions
et que tout cela était le fait de
l'ultra droite jean-christophe buisson
vous qui avez des d amitié pour
l'histoire de l'europe
vous avez sans doute un point de vue sur
ce sujet est-ce que la comparaison est
justifié on est totalement justifiée
elle elle s'inscrit dans une stratégie
qu'on a bien repéré et qui ne date pas
de ce week-end qui est devant nous a
expliqué qu'en france il ya le chaos
c'est à dire le ratio national marine le
pen et emmanuel macron comme s'ils
n'existaient rien ni sur leur côté nenê
entre eux parce qu on rappellera que
marine le pen entre autres avaient
appelé à manifester sur les
champs-elysées bien sur mes skis et la
violence des terres mais c'est quand
même quelque chose que la peste brune
c'est les mots ont un sens la paix
secondes ça veut vraiment dire les
défilés de nuremberg des années trente
du parti national socialiste allemand
qu'il y ait eu des gens d'extrême mois
dans ces manifestions c'est évident il
ya eu aussi des gens d'extrême gauche la
preuve en est qu'on eut quelques slogans
on a eu des drapeaux de che guevara on a
eu des des tags anarchie
des tags anti flics anti et a donc
évidemment que ce mouvement a
cristallisé aussi des gens plus plus
extrême que la grande masse des gilets
jaunes qui sont des braves gens
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les
interpellations les 103 qui ont été
interpellés lors en une aide à midi sur
intel
penney avoué qu'il n'y avait aucune
personne fichiers à l'extrême droite
parmi les sans interpeller donc il a
expliqué qu'en fait extrêmement était
venu mettre le bazar au début puis après
ils ont disparu effectivement il y avait
peut-être des gens d'extrême gauche donc
on voit très bien que le problème c'est
que la réalité revient dans le visage de
l'état qui est que ce n'est pas l'ultra
droite qui a monté ces manifestations il
ya vraiment là également un mouvement
populaire pas très bien organisé donc
sur lequel ne gouverne on n'a pas de
prise il est en panique
il est dans le désarroi donc quand ils
en panique ont brandi le drapeau de
l'antifascisme parce que c'est
évidemment quelque chose d'assez
fédérateur mais ça ne répond pas du tout
aux revendications des uns des uns et
des autres et notamment du gilet jaune
on vous pose la question sur twitter
êtes vous choqué par gérald darmanin
quand il déclare que c'est la peste
brune qui a manifesté sur les champs
elysées et vous êtes 74% à nous répondre
oui vous continuez à voter évidemment
sur twitter hashtag point de vue arnaud
chant premier trianon moi je dois avouer
que quand gérald harlin nous a dit ça
hier puisque sauf que j'étais faisait
partie des intervieweurs j'ai trouvé ça
tellement excessif que j'ai même pas
relevé mais j'ai sans doute eu tort
et ça m'a étonné de votre part
effectivement c'est excessif et ça a été
très bien dit en fait ils cherchent à
planter un décor le décor c'est nous ou
le fascisme
il le sait de le construire en france
c'est leur a réussi aux dernières
présidentielles il aimerait reproduire
ça y compris aux européennes montre et
qui a rien entre les deux il s'appuie
sur la montée des fascistes ou
néofasciste en europe et c'est un
phénomène effectivement qu'on peut
constater pour dire que voilà ça déborde
partout mais il reste des forces
politiques diverses et variées et on
voit bien chez les gilet jaune que il ya
certes une sur représentation des
électeurs de marine le pen une
sur-représentation des lecteurs de gens
qui ont mis une représentation très
forte des électeurs d'emmanuel macron
lui-même de fillon y compris le brugnon
voilà donc c'est un mouvement très
directif alors il ya eu une sélection
qui s'est fait quand même sur qui veut
monter jusqu'à paris et qui à paris veut
aller sur les champs elysées plutôt que
à d'autres points de rassemblement donc
là ça a été un phénomène d'entonnoir qui
a fini par effectivement concentrer les
plus déterminés on va dire voilà mais ça
reste une expression populaire
quant aux pavés qui ont été retirés
démonstration a été faite que c'était en
travaux et qu'on fait les pavés étaient
déjà retiré depuis un certain temps et
que les gros plans des chaînes infos sur
sur a7 est juste une parenthèse sur les
chaînes info on a passé la journée à
voir les images des émeutes uation
champs elysées il n'y a pas eu une image
des mobilisations en province qui
représentait 90 % du mouvement il n'y a
pas eu une image de la mobilisation de
la difficile des filets contre la
violence faite aux femmes qui avaient
lieu le même jour qui était très
importante
voilà donc il ya quand même une une une
obsession d'aller chercher ce qui est le
plus sulfureux et qui sait aujourd'hui
les intérêts de la ma chronique y trouve
effectivement un nouveau cadre audi va
poser si je peux compléter une
exagération c'est de la violence parce
que l'ordre lors du 1er janvier ou lors
de d'autres manifestants de jardiner
c'est dix fois pire que ça il ya eu très
peu de vitrines brisées je sais même pas
s'il ya une seule brisé c'est très
spectaculaire il ya ya il ya un camion
qui a été brûlé lors face et par rapport
à ce qu'on peut voir le 1er janvier et
le 31 décembre la saint sylvestre c'est
rien du tout dans leur temps emmanuel
macron avec mon ami rochus là dessus
marie mai car l'une valentin il est trop
jeune pour avoir manifesté sûrement je
crois qu'il n'avait pas les problèmes
qui est justifié qu'on manifeste
aujourd'hui
goûtez moi je trouve que c'est une
supercherie de politique politicienne
une manière d'instrumentaliser ces
revendications qui sont absolument
respectable et cet irrespect est
inacceptable et ne vraiment pas ce
ministre les violences ou six sont une
forme de respect non les violences sont
bien sûr c'est une forme d'irrespect
mais il ya une exaspération très forte
évidemment dans le lot dans tous ces
gens qui manifestent ya des gens qui
n'en peuvent plus qu'ils n'en peut plus
de ne pas être écoutés s'est fait quand
même des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années que ça que c'est le cas j'ai
encore j'ai apporté plein de livres j'ai
apporté celui-là plaidoyer pour une
gauche populaire est écrit en 2007
notamment par christophe guilluy qui ne
cesse de répéter que il ya 60% des
classes des français qui sont ces
classes populaires et moyennes que
personne n'écoute
et qui n'en peuvent plus qu'ils ne
votent pas et qui souffre et qui perdent
du pouvoir d'achat année après année ces
gens là n'en peuvent plus ils le disent
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas l'heur de plaire
à monsieur macron et que voulez-vous en
démocratie c'est la tyrannie de la
majorité c'est tant mieux construit ici
par les traîtres aux nazis qu'on va
dans leur colère au contraire on va même
la raviver il me semble alexis poulain
je me tourne vers vous en désespoir de
cause en me disant peut-être que
quelqu'un va défendre le gouvernement
moi j'y étais samedi j'ai fait un
reportage pour le monde moderne
j'ai vu personne de fascistes j'ai vu
des gens vêtus ou ak vous semblez chance
d'exister sur les champs elysées vous
pouvez regarder le reportage on était au
milieu des lacrymogènes on était avec
les gens on a vu les différentes
barricades on a vu aussi la la violence
le dispositif policier qui était là pour
protéger
monsieur mâcon qu'il vienne me chercher
vraiment c'était personne ne passera la
place de la concorde est en fait dès le
matin très tôt les gilets jaunes
arrivent en disant mons était
désorganisé on va bloquer la place de
l'étoile ça dure dix minutes
là les crs était plutôt bon enfant
disent non mais attendez on va essayer
de descendre fait un cortège le cortège
se faire on laisse passer les gens et
puis arrive la première confrontation
avec la des tirs de grenade comme j'ai
rarement vu ou le l'air était
complètement dans un brouillard lacrymo
et des gens qui manifestaient pour la
première fois été assez étonné de cette
violence là même s'il a retenu ce qu'il
faut voir là c'est le désespoir les gens
qui étaient dans la rue c'était des
travailleurs handicapés qui ne sont pas
reconnus qui gagnent 800 euros par mois
des élèves infirmières qui avec les
mesures du gouvernement bat n'arrivent
plus à payer leur loyer des gens qui
sont retraités qui sont là pour leurs
enfants pour aussi dire c'est pas
possible
si on continue comme ça ça ne va pas
marcher c'est pas des gens qui votent
c'est pas des gens qui sont forcément
politisée qui sont là pour en découdre
avec mac rose c'est des gens qui disent
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'on est en
train de nous rendre ce progrès qui en
fait une régression absolue on regarde
la grande bretagne
on va sur le monde moderne traduire le
rapport du rapporteur de l'onu sur la
pauvreté en grande bretagne
c'est un pays qui a vécu un miracle
libéral qui est en train de revenir à
l'ère de dickens simplement parce que la
pauvreté c'est un choix de politique
c'est à dire qu'on décide à un moment
quand la crise de 2008 arrive de ne pas
aider les plus fragiles de me payer le
plus pauvre de faire les politiques se
disant pour relancer la croissance pour
faire du ruissellement qui ne servent à
rien et ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui en
france c'est quoi ces des politiques qui
servent exactement à ça c'est à dire à
faire de l'argent là où l'argent est
mais finalement ça coûte un poignant de
dengue d'aider ces gens là alors on ne
va plus les aider il va falloir qu'ils
soient responsables et qu'ils se
débrouillent tout seuls
là ils sont dans la rue pour dire on
veut pas de ce monde là alors si c'est
ça le progrès on
pas de ce progrès là quand même il
aurait pu défiler pacifiquement ils ont
défilé pacifiquement je tiens à le dire
l'esma des provocations politiques de
casse il ya eu alors déjà aucune vitrine
on a sur les champs elysées aucune
vitrine de casser on a eu quoi des
barricades avec bien sûr quelques gens
de l'extrême gauche avec des chiens qui
est très très contents de faire un gain
fait d'armes où effectivement des gens
un peu énervé mais face aussi à la
réponse des crs vous verrez sur la vidéo
vous avez une femme en fauteuil roulant
qui se met face à un camion de crs et
qu'il empêche de passer les crs décembre
pour essayer de la poussée elle reste
les gilets jaunes arrivent et finalement
ils font demi tour mais c'est des gens
qui sont désespérés
j'ai on ne va pas là dans cette rue
simplement pour dire on va aller casser
non on est là pour se faire voir et
entendre sans violence un soutien que ça
mais de 15 ans qui a plus une
manifestation en france conséquente sans
actes de violence casino casp à neuf au
total vous le congrès a été le cas lors
de la loi travail pourquoi les citoyens
ajoute qu'il a croisés ivan rioufol
absolue voilà il y avait des spectateurs
de tous les codes des observateurs dont
mondial en termes moi je trouve que ces
pavés ça fait quand même penser beaucoup
à mai 68 que personne n'a d'ailleurs
qualifié de peste brune
à l'époque les barricades intéressant
moi je trouve dans ce mouvement
c'est qu'en fait on a l'impression que
c'est le contraire de mai 68 en mai 68
des étudiants et quartier latin qui
jamais ne connaîtrait des problèmes que
connaissent aujourd'hui ceux qui
manifestent sont allés à la rencontre
avec sartre à leur tête les ouvriers de
boulogne-billancourt pensons que c'est
devriez aller les accompagner dans leur
lutte dans volonté de faire la
révolution
exactement et les ouvriers
qu'est-ce-qu'il normandie d'écouté moi
j'ai du boulot
premièrement deuxièmement moi je pars la
révolution moi je veux le cadre des jeux
plus de sécurité et je plusse davantage
en ce qui a trait à la révolution
attendait non justement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé si vous lisez paul yonnet un
voyage au centre du malaise français qui
analyse très bien ce mouvement dit à
partir de ce moment là c'est assez cadre
là ces jeunes là plutôt qui sont ensuite
devenus qu'on fait l'ena qu'on fait
sciences po qui sont devenus des
journalistes qui ont faim sont devenus
des
des bobos puis surtout des gens qui font
partie de l'ère du qui ont considéré que
c'est ces ouvriers là ce qui était la
figure tutélaire habituel de la gauche
étaient des beaufs racistes et ils ont
substitué à cette figure tutélaire
traditionnel immigrés alors ça s'est
passé depuis 40 ans et qu'est ce que
disent maintenant ces gens là ils disent
écoutez le cadre que vous avez fait
voler en éclats maintenant on le veut et
c'est là toute la structure toute la
sécurité tout la protection que la
gauche était censé m'apporter pour les
cas était censée se battre je la veux
aujourd'hui plus bas au plus aucun parti
politique ne représentent ces gens-là et
seules personnes qui font les bons
constats mais en proposant des solutions
qui sont excusez moi mais insupportable
c'est le front national
d'une part au fait le rassemblement
national appelez ça comme vous voudrez
et d'une certaine mesure la france a
soumise mais quelle france a soumises on
en parlera pour les actions isolées
puissent voir spector mais c'est vrai
que c'est ces perdants de la
mondialisation celle votre up et
l'insultent des ministres l'insultent de
la classe dirigeante c'est exactement
l'erreur qu'on fait les démocrates c'est
de traiter ces gens là comme des
untermenschen des gens qui n'ont pas le
droit à la parole comme des abrutis des
pauvres qui fument des clopes avec leur
diesel ça ne fait que renforcer un
courant de dégagisme qui est déjà
présent de sous-stations fois mais en
france la dissidente en cas d'importante
chômage et certains choix d'un diamant
la luge de destruction des corps
intermédiaires les partis politiques la
sernam en mai avant les syndicats les
associations font des trop fort et des
croyants qui ont été détruits quand même
très cyniquement depuis une quinzaine
d'années et qui vont aujourd'hui il n'y
a aucune capacité d'encadrer mouvements
sociaux et de trouver un débouché il n'y
a pas d'interlocuteurs
cette fonte autodétruit efforts et un
tiers ils ont été nuls tout selon les
installations permet
de donner l'impression d'avoir une
réponse politique alors qu'il n'y en a
pas parce qu'évidemment 6 imaginons par
l'absurde qui n'est pas accusé l'extrême
droite qu'est ce qu'ils auraient répondu
à ce qui s'est passé samedi ils ont
aucune réponse et merci la création d'un
haut conseil de transition pour la
transition
mais avant je laisse la parole aux eaux
le dernier mot aux internautes
vous êtes assez partagé un le monsieur
baby nous dit la violence décrédibilise
le mouvement des gilet jaune alors que w
dit au contraire le gouvernement essaye
de nous faire peur avec la montée des
extrêmes
le problème de cette manif c'est qu'il
ya des gens qui protestent sur des
sujets très différents
voilà un autre internaute qui me disent
et il a eu beaucoup de casse nous
n'avons pas vu les mêmes images imagine
que si elles mêmes images que que vous
les intervenants et nicole nous dit il
est inadmissible de ne pas immédiatement
bloqué les casseurs ce qui d'après la
police peut se faire si on leur donne
l'ordre une dernière question vous
quittez surpasser l'équipement est ce
que vous avez l'impression que les
policiers ont d'abord laissé faire entre
guillemets sont pas laissés faire ils
ont été assez souple
moi j'ai vu des scènes où je me disais
oh là là ils vont taper les manifestants
et finalement non il y avait quelque
chose de l'ordre de n'essayez pas de
taper pour casser le mouvement
donc il ya eu très peu de volant ce
malgré ce que vous pensez le ressenti
quand vous voyez que quelques barricades
oui effectivement c'était des noeuds là
d'affrontement mais la majeure partie
des gens qui étaient là fuyait ces deux
affrontements c'est-à-dire qu'ils aient
ces gens-là décrédibilise le mouvement
je veux pas être là donc vous aviez en
fait du reflux permanent entre les gens
qui manifestaient qui partait de la
barricade et qui revenait mais les
policiers ont finalement étaient pas
remonter ou et là où c'était le plus dur
c'était vraiment au niveau de la place
de la concorde parce qu'il fallait pas
passer
et pour cause parce que l'assemblée et
l'elysée n'était pas loin je le disais
le président de la république on l'a
appris grâce à nos confrères du journal
du dimanche
s'apprête à annoncer la création d'un
haut conseil pour le climat et alors il
va annoncer la création de ce haut
conseil
je vous jure si c'est pas une blague au
conseil national de la transition
énergétique qui lui existe déjà
donc tout ça est assez formidable en
tout cas on a trouvé quelqu'un qui
trouve ça formidable c'est barbara
pompili député la république en marche
de sensibilité écologique
je suis contente de voir d'ailleurs qu'
il va y avoir un haut comité pour le
climat qui va être créée et qui va
justement réunir tous ces corps
intermédiaires ce qu'on appelle les
corps intermédiaires donc en fait c'est
la bonne réponse et la réponse adaptée à
la colère bas en tout cas ça permet de
renouer un dialogue avec tous ceux qui
sont sur les territoires et ça c'est
important car une volonté c'est une
bonne idée quand il faut recréer les
conditions du dialogue non si vous
voulez un soutien de cette mesure peut
être demandé à jean christophe aux
autres personnes soit plutôt que vous ne
devrez pas chez moi
effectivement c'est un énième comité
théodule dont on voit pas très bien ce
qu'il pourrait faire de plus que le
conseil national de la transition
écologique qui existe depuis 2013 et qui
complètent le conseil national du
développement durable sachant que le
conseil économique et social a été
complétée d'un e g61 pas très longtemps
puisque maintenant il également
environnementales mais aussi les
commissions du développement durable de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
avec ça on se demande comment ce qu'on
arrive encore appelé mais le problème
c'est qu'on a du mal à comprendre
premièrement à quoi servira ce comité
théodule signer sinon que pascal canfin
et deux autres personnes nommées à ce
comité là ont appelé de leurs voeux dans
une tribune qui est parue dans le point
une
une adhésion enfin le fait de faire
rentrer dans le comité des citoyens
c'est le grand truc heureusement c'est
la démocratie participative précise
juste que pascal canfin le patron du wwf
pour la france association écologiste
bien connu et que c'était un ancien et
ancien ministre est ce que ce que ça
montre surtout c'est que emmanuel macron
né sait pas quoi faire d'abord en haute
au monde pourquoi il n'ya que ça
semblerait être une réponse à ce qui se
passe avec les jets les genoux et
pourquoi est ce que cette réponse n'est
que écologique effectivement le
mouvement des gels et jaune est partie
suite à une augmentation du de l'essence
mais il ne signe il ne ne parle pas que
de la transition écologique premièrement
et deuxièmement on aimerait avoir un
président qui a une vision et non pas
qui remet entre les mains de comité
constitué soit d'experts soit des gens
tirés au sort parce que c'est ça que
pascal canfin et consorts suggère le
fait de dessiner l'avenir de la nation
bon alors à coûter cher un peu embêté
qui parmi voir envie de soutenir ce haut
conseil
moi je voudrais selon le comité
économique et social enfin l'idée
c'était de faire mes conseils
bien sûr le conseil économique là on
avait quelque chose justement qui
fonctionne avec une représentativité
justement plus large qui travaille aussi
de manière intellectuelle suffisamment
bien fait et internationale pourquoi
créer
un énième comité effectivement théodule
qui va servir à quoi en fait à faire
valoir et mal macron parce qu'il va
montrer qui fait une action
il est déjà championne of the earth il a
un badge qu'on éduque a été donnée à
l'onu il a fait le moine planète ce
mythe où il a fait des selphy avec
arnold schwarzenegger super il fait déjà
beaucoup pour sauver la planète elle son
téléphone
moi je trouve que ça suffit il faut
laisser les gens qui sauve la planète
sauver la planète il faut surtout
arrêter de prendre les français pour des
idiots
je pense que les gens sont dans la rue
pour ça c'est pas une réponse déjà les
enjeux climatiques ne se décrète pas et
ne se résolvent pas à l'échelle
nationale ça on le sait nos voitures
qu'on va vendre parce qu'elles sont
diesel parce qu'elles sont les sens
seront dans un second marché dans des
pays d'afrique dans des pays d'asie
ailleurs et ils seront rachetés elle
continue de rouler pendant 15 ans et la
presse pour la matière de carbone donc
qu'est ce sens qu'est ce qu'on veut dire
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
il faudrait faire en fait un comité
simple un comité sur la fiscalité et
dire comment on fait une fiscalité juste
aujourd'hui les gens qui sont dans la
rue aujourd'hui ils disent mais pourquoi
c'est toujours nous qui payons via des
taxes cacher ou via simplement des
impôts il faut aujourd'hui s'il faut
s'il faut un comité utile et si emmanuel
macron veut sauver son gouvernement et
sa tête c'est simplement mettre sur la
table une commune un comité sur la
fiscalité la redistribution et au niveau
européen pas seulement au niveau
français pose la question je vous passer
la parade contre 8,1 me sont venues
trigano mais je la donne d'abord à nos
internautes être favorable à la création
d'un haut conseil pour le climat vous
êtes quand même un tiers à penser que
oui ce qui peut-être voir équilibré avec
ce plateau même si solis nous dit un
comité qui va nous coûter un bras
magnifique point d'exclamation temps
n'est que vers 34 ajoute la création
d'un haut conseil
faut-il en rire ou en pleurer
le cee le web l'émission qui va être
confié à ce comité c'est de contrôler si
les
réforme proposée par le gouvernement
pour l'environnement n'auront pas un
impact trop négatif sur les questions
sociales économiques de la population
voilà soutiennet d'alerté sociale et
connaissent un gros comment on encaisse
les réformes environnementale
socialement économiquement il ya déjà du
monde pour s'occuper de ça s'appelle les
parlementaires dans une majorité les
députés à quoi ils servent à voter les
lois bon non depuis longtemps mais au
moins à faire remonter les infos de leur
circonscription et allait pouvoir dire
au gouvernement ça ne passe pas les gens
ne se comprennent pas où les gens
souffrent localement parce que bien sûr
qu'il ya une déconnexion peut pas leur
reprocher à tous les gouvernements
d'être déconnecté de la réalité de la
vie de ses concitoyens
donc ça c'est mécanique mais au moins ce
lien qui était le parlementaire et les
partis politiques permettait cela or
avec en marche il ya plus lien puisque a
pas de parlementaires puisqu'ils n'ont
pas drôle avouer qu'ils sont méprisés
mais vous regardez les manifestations
bien gilet jaune le seul qu'on a vue qui
a dit je suis un cahier de doléances
vivant et sur pattes
c'était françois ruffin qui va avec son
cahier demander qu'est ce que vous ferez
la france nation si vous avez [ __ ] est
votre rôle c'est d'être là de demander
pourquoi les gens sont à la rue alors
qu'il pleut il fait froid en disant mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup de députés y faire sa vie les
députés en marchant ont complètement
baissé les bras c'est à dire que ils
considèrent pour ceux de province
considère que de toute façon ils sont
plus écoutés par le gouvernement et par
les consignes qui sont tous deux très
jeunes parisiens sur diplômante parfois
ils sont en progrès c'est quand même
aussi
ils sont certes agressé mais en tout cas
ils viennent ils vont plus défendre des
mesures sur lesquelles ils n'ont pas
leur mot à dire c'est ça le deal et que
effectivement on les associe aux
processus de décision et puis après ils
redescendent en circonscription pour
défendre la politique d'armement en là
comme ils sont associés à rien et
beaucoup se demandent ce qu'ils font là
bon bah reilly redescendre et puis ils
se planquent voilà tout ce qui est
agaçant agaçant en fait c'est que il
n'ya pas à juger de la soutenabilité de
mesures qui sont nécessaires pour
l'écologie le gouvernement le rôle du
gouvernement du président de la
république et du gouvernement c'est de
faire en sorte de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour que les mesures qui
doivent être prises pour l'environnement
soit acceptable et supportable par les
gens typiquement cette augmentation du
coût de l'essence
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de solution
interne hâtive acceptable à un coût
normal un coût acceptable qui permette à
des gens qui habitent dans des zones
rurales de se déplacer d'aller faire
leurs courses ou d'aller à leur travail
il n'y en a pas moi j'ai acheté une
voiture hybride qui m'a coup
et très cher j'ai la vigne est un qui
qui prétend que je ne pollue pas je
n'arrive pas à brancher ma voiture les
quelques fois où j'arrive à la branche
et de la branche 6 ou 7 heures je fais
10 km avec le race béton je pollue
horrible donc voilà donc ça a envoyé
personne n'en veut ou alors si vous avez
la voiture complètement électrique que
vous débranchez pendant six ou sept
heures avant que de pouvoir faire vos
trente bornes au bout 50 bornes ou celle
que vous devez équivaut donc six ou sept
heures ça veut dire si vous faites 300
km sur l'autoroute
vous devrez savoir premier méga pause au
milieu pour se rejoindre votre poids moi
je pense que c'est la pire des réponses
que pouvait faire le gouvernement
d'abord parce qu'évidemment ça nous
rappelle clément saucy voulait enterrer
un problème et une commission on est
vraiment dans ce registre là ensuite
effectivement il ya déjà un conseil qui
existe et surtout c'est quelque chose
c'est une réponse d'énarques s'est elle
a créé une commission de ce type là où
un conseil de ce type là d'abord ils
auraient dû être créés avant en
concertation parce que c'était avant
d'augmenter les taxes et avant de
décider d augmenter jusqu'en 2022 qu'il
fallait créer ce donc là on sent bien
que c'est encore une réponse de
quelqu'un de paniquer en dix ans dans
l'effet de panique en bouche on fait
quelque chose donc ancré ont créé ce
comité alors que la réponse elle est ni
nationales et internationales et locales
et laurent berger de la cfdt a fait des
propositions qui me semble absolument
pas idiote c'est de réfléchir comment on
associer effectivement les collectivités
locales les entreprises à des moyens
alternatifs on ne pas polluer notamment
dans le trajet puisque c'est quand même
le noeud du problème le trajet domicile
travail pourquoi les entreprises ne sera
pas plus sollicités pour aider
effectivement à cette fameuse transition
écologique qui permet de moins polluer
sans que ça coûte horriblement cher en
tout cas de manière provisoire donc
toutes ces réflexions là c'est ça qu'il
faut avoir
effectivement c'est les corps
intermédiaires comme les syndicats
qu'ils proposent aux dix associations
c'est sûrement pas des énarques réunis
même si l'as aussi quelques citoyens en
gilet jaune
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va répondre
effectivement aux revendications des
gilets jaunes ou d'autres aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est une réponse
technocratique recrues en urgence d
intermédiation totalement artificielle
moi c'est aussi ce que vous disiez sur
les associés les entreprises à la
transition écologique on ne le fait pas
assez de ce comité il dit quoi il dit
simplement que ce gouvernement comme les
instances européennes sont totalement
aux ordres des lobbys j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de responsables politiques
monter au front quand on a appris que
volkswagen trick truquée ces tests
diesel quand on a appris que nissan
truquée ces tests diesel c'était en
juillet les constructeurs automobiles
font à peu près ce qu'ils veulent c'est
à dire qu'on ne les oblige pas déjà
proposé des produits propres les
voitures polluent et c'est normal on ne
les oblige pas à faire de la r&d à
sortir sur le marché des voitures
propres non ça on les laisse faire
et puis quand elles sont à la faute eh
bien il ya très peu de sanctions très
très peu parce qu'on a besoin d'emplois
parce que c'est le chantage à l'emploi
parce que une semaine avant
l'arrestation de carlos ghosn vous aviez
monsieur darmanin monsieur macro et
monsieur le maire avec carlos ghosn
lusine dans le nord de la france mais
non c'est super il ya quelques il ya
quelques emplois qui ont été créés la
merci beaucoup monsieur grandes
entreprises ya la même chose de certains
états qui sont des groupes aux meilleurs
comme les etats unis c'est la chine et
l'inde qui sont une opportunité elle
marronniers ce bal masqué qui ferme ses
centrales mais ouvrent des usines à
charbon
la france progresse progresse en
émission c'est parce qu'il voulait
fermer les centrales nucléaires
justement si si mais qui sont pas la
france progresse il ya un an on pollue
plus depuis la cap 21
on dirait que ça grimpe au lupus chacun
un dernier mot laisser à nos internautes
l on nous dit rien ne dit que dans cinq
ans ils ne vont pas trouver finalement
le diesel peu polluants
lila rappelle que 80 % des taxes entre
guillemets écolo ne vont pas à
l'écologie
et si chez nous d'ici sa priorité celles
d' emmanuel macron et et l'écologie il
ne ferait pas tout pour tuer les petites
lignes de trains film aux filles dans
cette histoire c'est à dire que on s'est
soumis aux discours écologiste un peu
catastrophique pour dire la planète en
danger la planète va mourir donc il faut
absolument faire des choses
immédiatement alors que je pense qu'on
était notamment les citoyens sur la voie
d'une transition écologique presque
naturel à faire des économies à faire
attention à faire le tri se passer de
façon assez progressive naturel et en
voulant obéir aux écologistes qui nous
annoncent tous les huit jours que c'est
la fin du monde que et bien finalement
on a sacrifié les fins de mois au profit
de la perspective d'une fin du monde et
on se sent obligé de prendre des mesures
draconiennes brutale immédiate
au lieu de faire cette transition
écologique sur le temps et ce qui fait
que le gouvernement aujourd'hui coincés
parce que l'impression qu'il faut des
réponses immédiates parce que la révolte
elle est présente écologistes c'est un
seul carburant là pour remplir un trou
manque à gagner dans les finances de
l'état à cause des cadeaux qui ont été
faits sur l' isf et ailleurs et là aussi
c'est la planète en danger il faut faire
quelque temps mais ça c'est pas un
argument c'est un fait les deux degrés
c'est un fait c'est pas un argument et
sur le fait qu'il va falloir changer de
modèle oui ça aussi c'est sur l'île mais
on ne veut pas changer ma belle tu fais
semblant le timing il est long et ça on
ne peut pas le gérer et aujourd'hui on
fait simplement semblant d'avoir des
mesures écologiques d'inciter les gens à
faire des choses mais on n'incite pas
les constructeurs on n'incite pas les
gros énergétivores les consuls enfin
total fait de l'argent avec du pétrole
c'est pas les grands murs on n'oblige
pas totale
petit rôle du rjr voilà les gros
pollueurs sont pas payés et toujours pas
voilà un commentaire
d'un internaute qui nous dit caroline
annoncée par l'insee vous savez pas ce
que vous êtes la seule à avoir ce prénom
sur ce plateau
caroline devrait pour l'emploi de son
véhicule à moins d'avoir une tesla
mettait ça c'est un peu plus cher
c'était si vous voulez les revendre dans
votre petite annonce alors on va parler
maintenant de la france a soumises y
avait une élection législative partielle
lire c'était dans l'essonne il fallait
trouver un successeur à manuel valls
démissionnaire de son poste de député
c'est le candidat soutenu par valls est
d'ailleurs par la république en marche
qui a été élue assez largement
mais avec une très grosse abstention
plus de 81% et puis la candidate de la
france insoumise farida amrani a fait un
score qui a sans doute déçus les gens de
son parti d'ailleurs alexis corbière
député france insoumise de la seine
saint denis l'a reconnu ce matin c'est
pas la grande pêche
ces milieux absentionnistes pourquoi il
faut le regarder
peut-être parce qu'on n'a pas assez
travaillé je vais en dire deux mots
là-dessus peut-être parce que
dernièrement aussi une séquence qui nous
était parfois un peu compliqué peut-être
aussi parce que nous sommes emportés
dans ce grand mouvement de mise à
distance des formations politiques je
pense qu'on a fait une petite erreur
aussi on a mené une campagne notamment
de deuxième tour type gauche rassemblée
c'était le le matériel de campagne où
les mes amis ont conclu qu en disant que
noël mamère ou je ne sais trop qui nous
monsieur hamon nous soutenaient où le
parti communiste
tout ça n'a rien produit à même genre et
trigano que se passe-t-il on pouvait
croire que cette ébullition sociale ça
profiterait à la france insoumise et
puis apparemment non non non c'est ça
profite à personne pour l'instant très
nettement et l'abstention est là pour
démontrer que ces mouvements sont en
fait un rejet du débat politique on n'y
croit plus et les partis qui pensent
capitaliser les mouvements sociaux c'est
lequel la france a soumis c'est qu'il ya
du rassemblement
marine le pen bon ne capitalise pas y'a
même pas deux secteurs sur dix qui se
sont déplacés rien ces personnes est ce
que dit alexis corbière est intéressant
il dit on à jouer la fibre union de la
gauche et c'est vrai que toute la gauche
a été se réunir derrière cette candidate
bon ça n'a rien donné parce que la
gauche ça ne parle plus y compris aux
électeurs traditionnels ou en tout cas
le le rassemblement des partis de gauche
n'a pas cet effet misé en dynamique
voilà qu'il avait un profil particulier
aussi une femme et d'un bras ni ce n'est
pas forcément le consensuel old republic
est un vote comme une paresse tous les
partis de côté tous les partis de gauche
et non pas forcément
vous savez très bien que comme une
césure au sein y compris au sein de la
france a soumis sur sur ce sur ce type
de profil
soutenu par les indigènes le l'addition
des partis de gauche qui
traditionnellement créer une dynamique
créée plus dynamiques dire que ce parce
que là parce que le candidat mais parce
qu'avec l'artiste radisson sas
exactement la même chose aux états unis
pour vous dire trump c'est le vote trump
c'était des petits blancs ont fait qu'il
y en a qui on nous a assez qu'on
privilégie des communautés et qu'on ait
un discours identitaire
moi je trouve ça assez inquiétant que
cette candidate qui n'a pas soutenu a
été soutenu mollement par dieudonné mais
qui était franchement soutenu par des
données et qui n'a rien dit au sujet de
ce soutien et or qui était soutenue par
la france est soumise elle avec mon ami
farid alilat toujours dit marwan
muhammad du ccr kétamine islamistes elle
s'est dit proche de médine qui est un
islamiste
du coup du temps mais je goodyear des
preuves une candidate idéale pour
incarner
c'est pas d'ambiguïté 1 c'est pas du
tout on n'est plus au niveau 2008 et là
on est franchement dans l'indigénisme
jusque là donc cette candidate
indigéniste jusque là aient eu le
soutien du ps des verts 2 évidemment de
la génération 2 après deux places
publiques de julien dray de bastien
faute de noël mamère d'emmanuel morel
son côté des jeunes hémois du monde que
cette femme ait des proximités avec le
payèrent de houria bouteldja qui est
quand même l'hymne raciste antisémite
qu'elle soit copine avec l'islamisme et
dean ou avec marouane la leur et j'en
passe et des meilleurs un jeune de la
république
exactement ils sont pas beaucoup mais
ils sont elle a écrit un livre aurait
bouté jacky son porte parole a notamment
écrit un brûlot anti sémite qu'elle a
qu'elle a politiquement intitulé les
blancs les juifs et nous etc est
absolument illisible
je vous renvoie un excellent article de
mars non marianne à ce sujet d'un auteur
on est très bien mais il ya un problème
de toute façon déjà au sein de l esprit
puisque effectivement ce que vous disiez
il ya une scission entre d'une part les
ailes et fit républicains qui sont très
attachés à la laïcité qui ont milité
pour la laïcité ou en 2017 et la lab
labanque est en train de prendre a les
filles de manière absolument très nette
puisque les militants républicains cette
annonce se sont fait bloquer de leur
page facebook de leur parti ne peuvent
plus accéder aux instances de leur parti
et a maintenant une dérive très
inquiétante de la fiq évidemment
symbolisée par la députée des logos
nôtre est protégé par jean luc mélenchon
qui d'asud de toit les filles et qui est
proche d'aubry à voter déjà des femmes
et partis indigènes de la république
eric coquerel
si eric coquerel et si vous savez
parfaitement qu'il ya un problème
d'infiltration de swing eric coquerel
eric qui fait les meetings avec les
indigéniste il ya clémentine autain qui
après qui appelle à faire mais tim
commun avec tariq ramadan
cinq ans et cinq ans on est passé à
autre chose je pense que la laisse que
ces matches on a l'impression qu'à une
double fracture sanaa france insoumise
globalement sur les sujets écologiques
avec les gilets jaunes on soutient qu'on
soutient pas alors qu'objectivement ils
protestent contre des mesures
écologiques et puis sur la sphère
communautarisme ou non là je pense qu'il
n'ya pas il ya des courants comme
partout c'est un mouvement c'est pas un
parti c'est encore plus compliqué à
organiser je crois qu'ils aient eu
effectivement des accointances de tel ou
tel candidat
avec des mouvements indigéniste c'est
indéniable mais c'est pas c'est
extrêmement grave comme beaucoup
d'autres choses mais c'est pas le parti
et the ring et la france a soumis ce
n'est ni antisémite ni racines et ses
animaux cette défaite elle elle veut
dire aussi quelque chose
les 80% d'abstention on peut pas les
mettre sous le tapis
c'est une élection locale c'est au local
que ça joue je pense aussi que le
vainqueur monsieur choix a fait une
campagne locale il est connu il a aussi
vers des prix bien sûr il a verrouillé
enfin il connaît très bien sa vie il son
territoire c'est bon on va pas non plus
sur une élection locale en faire un
exemple national le ps n'existe plus
mais c'est pas passé par un travail mais
parce que le ps a choisi la ligne valdes
d'un côté la ligne hollande de l'autre
il s'évanouit capes la seconde allait
tout à l'heure les gens normal volk la
11eme crise politique
argent si les gens en ont ras-le-bol de
la répression politique aujourd'hui il
ya besoin de clarification politique
je suis bien d'accord il va falloir que
les choses soient maîtres se mise au
clair en faisant votre formation que
défend tél bon eh bien la france a
soumis c'est clair il ya un truc qui
s'appelle l'avenir comment il suffit de
lire tout est écrit noir vous le savez
bien mais vous savez bien c'est déjà si
ces sessions terrible 5e pas aussi sûr
terrible autres choses ne vont pas nous
tirer l'arrivée vous auriez morel c'est
un républicain extrêmement jaloux elle
arbore la socialiste candidat voilà ben
voilà c'est la vision de son parti qui
créa était telle dans la tradition pop
ray nice qui est très
quitterait l'aï très républicain et qui
arrivent et qui rejoint les filles il ya
vraiment des courants et depuis la
création depuis le front gauche n'est
pas connu à la légère je tenais front de
gauche il y avait il y avait des
courants très diverses
voilà il ya toujours ici courant à
gauche c'est ce cancer espérance et
l'étirement 10 et les anti fascistes
voilà c'est ça les les anti fasciste au
moment des forums sociaux européen dans
un ait 90 ont 10 l'arrivée des barbus à
aux tribunes c'est du fascisme et les
tiers monde y sont énoncées des imams
donc c'est la religion des machins et la
scission si free la wii dans la gauche
ap les années 70 ces deux courants
hockey tennis mais l'islamisme
depuis les années soixante dix on a
compris des choses et encore pas très
longtemps changé que stan honey qui
vient aussi régulièrement annonce qu'il
ya un groupe qui avait un groupe de
soutien je ne sais pas ce que c'est
exactement un groupe de soutien créé au
sein de la rfi qui a été dissous et ou
excuser les filles parce qu'il voulait
organiser avec des algériens qui avaient
souffert du terrorisme en algérie
1 une réunion sur l'entrisme islamistes
dans les syndicats
donc évidemment la frange indigéniste
est donc promis à nice parce que
finalement c'est pareil
de là les fils et énervé et avec le
soutien des écoles crèches ce groupe de
soutien a été viré de la fiq donc c'est
bon mais tous attendaient en ce moment
vous savez il ya aussi beaucoup de
campagnes personnelles pour la liste des
européennes qui va bientôt sortir à la
fin vous allez entendre tout et
n'importe quoi j'aurais beaucoup de gens
qui par d'accrocher à droite qui vont
dire des choses sur les plateaux
honnêtement il y a une chose claire avec
la france a soumis c'est que c'est pas
la ligne
ce n'est pas celle que vous venez de
dire qui est bien sûr des problèmes et
depuis quelques années mais c'est plus
le cas aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya une
clarification cuir marche n'a pas été
remis en question à la fin je peux vous
donner le point de vue des deux
internautes ça peut vous ça peut
inspirer vos réflexions sur twitter on
vous a posé la question après la défaite
à evry pensez-vous la france insoumise
en difficulté vous êtes 74% à nous
répondre oui et ce commentaire c'est la
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon qui
dessert
à la france un sou mais ses intérêts
c'est ce qui se passait non pas evry
mais à ivry ce week-end c'est la
recomposition du parti communiste
français qui a mis à sa tête un homme
qui s'appelle fabien roussel naissant
kong live et qui va beaucoup embêté la
france insoumise
parce que la stratégie de mélenchon
était d'être leader de la gauche pour
être candidat à la prochaine
présidentielle et qu'une partie de la
gauche plurielle de celles qui ne sont
pas réunies dallas candidats pour des
raisons qu'on ait évoqué mais peut-être
aussi pour des raisons de stratégie
électorale ou électoralistes eh bien on
va se retrouver dans une situation
inédite c'est à dire que il ya toute une
partie la france a soumis ce qui
comptait c'est effectivement la
stratégie de mélenchon qui est je suis
le chef je me prépare la prochaine
présidentielle et je suis le seul à
gauche et je domine toute la gauche ps
écolo parti communiste et fabien roussel
ne l'entend pas de cette oreille et iris
de restructurer autour de lui y compris
des transfuges du parti socialiste des
gens de là les filles on a vu que ce
week end je prends une une responsable
de la france a soumises de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes est chargé
notamment des questions écologistes qui
quitte le parti favori omar el d'arc
voilà peut-être à les semer
donc elle se mêle à une militante débat
absolument c'est une responsable qui
manie son lit sur les sujets écologistes
réalisent donc une redéfinition des
gauches en ce moment peut-être entre
autres à cause de ce qu'on évoque aussi
mais c'est pour ça que ce week-end était
pas bon du tout pour la france parce que
c'est incompatible vous comprenez bien
qu'on ne peut pas la presse adressé aux
quoi vous haussez la théorie de plus que
les deux gauches sont incompatibles mais
il risque aussi d'y emmener pas être
immigrationniste socialistes et au delà
dix années 80 c'était irrégulier dans
les 110 soit la mère si elle veut gagner
la gauche que le script à tous les
quatre jeunes aura que quelques minutes
pour parler d'un dernier sujet l'onu
propose à ses membres de signer au début
du mois prochain je crois que ce sera à
l'occasion d'un sommet à marrakech
impact sur les migrations en gros l'idée
de ce pacte c'est que les migrations
sont un mouvement inéluctable qu'il faut
mieux et en prendre acte et essayer de
les organiser le mieux possible les pays
membres de l'onu se déchirent sur ce
sujet écoutez successivement trois
responsables politiques qui sont opposés
à ce pacte il s'agit de benjamin
netanyahu le premier ministre israélien
de mateusz mort aviez qui
moravia qui je dis bien le premier
ministre polonais et le vice-chancelier
autrichien heinz christian strache
aurait pu y at-il entre les noms
concrètes et in writing d'impact fort
molitor consult rapporte qu'aux nantis
inra clic nick tosches du dessous alors
on aurait pu aussi vous donner des
propos de donald trump puisque les états
unis ne voteront pas apparemment la
belgique non plus ne voterait pas ce
pacte en revanche emmanuel macron lui
trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
et voici ses arguments le texte non
engageant et non contraignant
juridiquement auquel cette négociation a
abouti et je considère un bon texte
parce qu'il permet d'améliorer la
coopération et il donne d'ailleurs des
lignes de solutions reposant sur un
meilleur partenariat en matière de
développement économique et éducatif en
matière de sécurité
un meilleur partenariat en termes aussi
de coopération entre les pays d'origine
de transit et d'arrivée et surtout un
meilleur partenariat en termes de lutte
contre les réseaux de trafiquants jean
christophe buisson si vous étiez
président de la république vous
signeriez ce papa ben oui puisque 1
engage à rien donc évidemment c'est ce
que dit emmanuel macron évidemment ça
n'engage à rien c'est un engagement et
non contraignant juridiquement et en
plus ça parmi les objectifs le respect
de la souveraineté de chaque état en
matière d'immigration c'est un paradoxe
total vient trouve totalement inutile ce
qui ce qui est assez intéressant dans
ses 23 objectifs de ce pacte j'en ai
noté quelques dents par exemple on va
enfin on veut créer un site internet
pour aider les migrants à se rendre dans
le pays qu'ils souhaitent en les aidant
au fur et à mesure de leur progression
l'objectif numéro 16 c'est d'accepter
les cultures des autres donc si on
arrive d'un pays où on pratique
l'excision parce que c'est une tradition
culturelle on peut arriver avec cette
pratique dans le pays qui nous accueille
c'est formidable
l'objectif 17 c'est punir tout discours
médiatique et ça ça devient un peu plus
graves qui tendrait à stigmatiser mais
en jeu parce qu'on n'a pas la
stigmatisation des migrants ces notes si
vous dites en france je n'ai pas envie
de voir des migrants sans être forcément
raciste nous incarner la peste brune et
bien vous êtes sommet vous l'état qui
responsable de ce citoyen de le punir ou
le média qui relaie cette information
est facultatif
la théorie c'est ça en fait l'objectif
c'est de faire du droit 2 me grâce aux
nouveaux droits de l'homme tout
simplement et de l'institut et de façon
internationale cessèrent droits de
l'homme alors attention sur sur la
migration des cédants allait bien sûr
donc c'est un homme le mènera au delà
des frontières dans transfrontières
n'est pas un droit de l'homme c'est ça
qui va leur institut et on se passe des
frontières moi je trouve que c'est une
bonne idée d'en faire un droit de
l'homme justement est d'avoir une
politique d'accueil réfléchi parce
qu'aujourd'hui le problème qu'on a c'est
qu'on dit non et qu'on est incapable et
de sécuriser la frontière et
d'accueillir donc il faut un moment
trouver une entente sur un problème qui
est qui n'est pas un problème qu'il
renvoie dire l'immigration c'est
l'histoire d'humanité ça a toujours été
enfin l'or dans cette ampleur vous avez
toujours eu des guerres des populations
déplacées
le commerce qui a fait migration d'abord
pour commencer
aujourd'hui le problème il est culturel
il est économique bien sûr c'est qu'on a
décidé de mettre la loi avant la morale
c'est-à-dire que quand on aide et moi
j'ai fait un débat sur la roya avec des
gens qui étaient là ils ont dit le
premier réflexe qu'on a quand on va
passer d'immigrants c'est de les aider
c'est pas parce que même qu'on soit pour
la frontière ou pas c'est qu'on n'a pas
le choix on est humain donc on va aider
quelqu'un qui est en détresse
axa non ça c'est être humain bon il faut
partir de ça en disant je trouve que et
c'est le rôle de l'onu d'être humain est
d'essayer de faire quelque chose un peu
d'eau dessus et de dire voyons formé par
ce qui m'inquiète oui mais non il faut
aussi s'organiser
si on peut même se mettre d'accord sur
un texte non engagement contraignant
mais au moins dire mais c'est pas le
suivre
c'est vraiment facile mais pas du tout
c'est là le sens des principes qui je
veux des grands principes non
législative et pacôme et night à ce
pollen s'est passé je comprends bien sûr
personne n'est naïf et bien sûr le port
gueydon contraignant mais vous avez ri
ce qui s'est passé très récemment encore
où ça vous avez eu une décision du
comité des droits de l'homme alors tout
ça est non-contraignant parce que bien
sûr
l'onu n'est pas une juridiction
française et on n'est pas censé la
france ne peut pas être sanctionné pour
ne pas pour avoir enfreint des traités
qu'elle a signés qu'est ce ça c'est la
théorie la pratique le comité des droits
de l'homme rend un arrêt aura une
décision en estimant que la décision de
la cour de cassation
donc je sais juridiction suprême
française et décision de la cour de
cassation sur baby loup était une
mauvaise décision
elle incite la france a rendu sa
décision interdisant à une jeune femme
voilée de travailler exactement une
femme qui n'était pas voilée qui part en
projet maternité qui revient voile et
tout ça dans une ambiance d'entrisme et
de montée du fondamentalisme islamiste
dont même de journalistes du monde
récemment ont fait un libre donc ce
n'est pas du tout un des lions est donc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé comme en
france at-il intime l'ordre à la france
de changer sa jurisprudence et que fait
bertrand louvel premier président de la
cour de cassation c'est pas rien dans
son discours d'intronisation là le 3
septembre 2018 il dit vous savez quoi
ils ont devrait changer d'un tueur et
présence pour se conformer à la décision
du comité des droits de l'homme
mais ce n'est pas tout ce n'est pas tout
vous avez un autre une autre décision
qui a été prise concernant une sanction
que la france a infligé à deux femmes
qui portaient la burqa donc le comité
des droits de l'homme des experts
estiment que là il ya là une
discrimination intersectionnelle basées
sur le genre et la religion donc en fait
la plaignante a saisi d'abord le nez
ensuite un groupe de seize d'experts 10
à la france dit ça va pas du tout il
faut que vous changez votre législation
et même que vous nous rendez un rapport
sur l'évolution de votre législation et
sur l'indemnisation pour vous frappe
ligne entre qu'est ce qui se passe un
sens une des plaignantes une femme qui
était sanctionné pour avoir porté la
burqa a entrevu une action devant les
juridictions françaises pour non respect
par la france des engagements pris
aux termes d'un traité donc en face à
vannes ça va devenir plus d'un an je
leur ai dit bien très bien ce qu'on peut
dire trigano c'est que on disait la même
chose de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme qu'on avait ajouté à la
constitution ont aujourd'hui les juges
considèrent les juges constitutionnels
constat qu'elle fait partie de la
constitution on à la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme on a
ajouté à la constitution c'est pas une
c'est pas un truc signé à l'onu enfin
donc vous voteriez moi ce que je devins
qu'on salue si vous voulez dans toute
cette histoire
laissez moi finir une phrase classe ce
que j'aurai consensus et c'est la
volonté des pays de se saisir de cette
question
la question de la migration qui est une
question qui aujourd'hui nous obsède
concerne quelques dizaines de millions
de personnes d'ici 2050 avec les
problèmes climatiques
c'est un milliard de personnes qui vont
se déplacer voilà par exemple la
hollande la moitié est sous l'eau
dunkerque presqu'île la bretagne sous la
flotte donc il y aura des migrations
nationale il y aura des migrations
intérieures européenne il y aura des
migrations planétaire donc ça va être un
enjeu colossal pour le 21e siècle
alors on peut essayer de se dire on va
se bunkériser on traite pas le sujet et
on continue voilà à monter des murs
comme on le fait partout dans le monde
ce qui a de plus en plus de murs qui ce
monde mais il faut absolument que les
pays se saisit cette question alors le
texte et critiqua parce que je pense
qu'il a fallu trouver un compromis et
qu'il faut quand même embarqué sur des
textes comme ça des pays tels que
l'arabie saoudite et d'autres pays pour
qu'ils sont les pays sous marins des
pays du golfe dont il faut embarquer
tout
on arrive à dire oui c'est un sujet et
oui on cherche des solutions ensemble
sa mise en faillite c'est indispensable
mais dans quel de l'union européenne
vous pensez bien qu'avec l'onu c'est
encore moins possible peut-être dans le
simple de toute façon contre
l'immigration elle arrive
elles vont être colossal mais quand elle
vivait à sauver de la grille monde
inégale l'onu
c'est un milliard de personnes qui ont
des chiens j'agace jeanne favret saada
madame la prochaine fois c'est le
troisième prévenu m
moi je lis des livres chez moi et j'en
amènerait à la rochelle limoges à la
migration c'est à dire que son ami pedro
alesis que c'était pour se saisir du
sujet ensemble
il faudrait qu'on est ensemble ce sujet
grâce va devenir obligatoire par le
biais de ce que je vous ai expliqué les
cèpes et ce partout il est signé et donc
décidé par des gens c'est un état une
voix et les gens qui ont intérêt à ce
que on accueille laure milan sont
beaucoup plus nombreux que les gens qui
ont intérêt les églises et surtout les
landais sont concernés dès aujourd'hui
de ce qu'on appelle par la migration il
et il est extrêmement régional allé au
liban vous verrez ce que c'est que le
problème de la migration dans les camps
je regardais l'hiver comme les familles
personne ne fréquentent pas les
migrations les cendres et l'aunis de la
migration et elle est extrême et c'est
tout ce qu'on voit là que les gens qui
traversent la méditerranée
c'est d'abord le fait de mafias de
passeurs c'est parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent à se faire et c'est un c'est
une petite traîne d'un problème il y est
explosif et qui ne fait que commencer et
d'imagés tout le monde quand il sortira
sauf qu'ils qui s'est retiré attend
peut-être européenne on le verra la
question twitter faut-il signé le pacte
de l'onu sur les migrations à bien vous
êtes 75 % à considérer que non c'est pas
un sondage a bien sûr ce sont ces sur
des réactions d'internautes et nicole
nous dit toutes les semaines un nouveau
pays indique ne pas vouloir signer ce
pacte
mais bien sûr
macron va le signer eux et la même
nicole nous dit ce sujet doit faire
l'objet d'un référendum tel est bien en
tout cas on a fait un référendum autour
de sur ce plateau sur ce sujet vous êtes
sûrement un échantillon représentatif
enfin partout les quatre points de vue
c'est fini pour ce soir vous retrouvez
maria mais les lombards demain à la même
heure au même endroit bonsoir à tous
[Musique]